élise gravel merci de nous accueillir
vous êtes et c'est le moins qu'on peut
se dire prolifique je lisais sur ce que
vous avez publié depuis quelques années
savez vous est-ce que vous tenez le
conte d'abord de combien de publication
de ce jeune je tiens pub c'est très
gênant mais on me dit que c'est au
dessus de 60 livres en tout 6 samedi
avait
décimé samedi lice grave elle capte et
mousse l'imaginaire des enfants depuis
20 ans si viviane ma dernière de huit
ans aime la lecture c'est grâce à cette
femme remarquable
[Musique]
notre vie alka afp j'ai trouvé la plus
drôle c'était la phrase ici qu'elle
rencontre fut remis
ses cheveux donné l'impression d'avoir
été dessiné par une enfant fâché oui des
petites phrases amusantes et bien
ciselés que les enfants retiennent des
morceaux d'imaginaire qui allument des
étoiles dans leurs yeux il y livre d'
élise gravel forme toute une
constellation dans le monde de l'édition
je parle un libraire samedi gelé dans
une libraire une librairie d'inventer
jésus montre moi tes titres
deleasa rôle c'est parmi les hôtes à qui
roulent le plus j'en recommande tout le
temps lui m'a dit par exemple le livre
sur les champignons moi je resterai
jamais marché mais il est là qu elle a
une touche qui fait qu'à peut aborder
tous les sujets c'est simple vous avez
certains dont la simplicité cessé en
fait c'est très compliqué je sais pas si
c'est un don dans mon club peut-être
mais je pense que ça se travaille la
vulgarisation entre les deux mains c'est
des sujets des fois complexes que
j'aborde des sujets scientifiques de
sujets politiques et tout ce qu'il faut
qu'un enfant de 4 ans comprennent ça
m'arrive d'être maman et ça m'a aidé des
humains sur rossi qui est d'avoir un
trouble de déficit de l'attention que je
suis capable de me suis capable de me
suivre moi même ou si je me trouve
intéressante longtemps ça veut dire que
probablement je vous connecter avec un
enfant il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
que j'ai un trouble de déficit c'est
presque devenu vous c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai j'ai un diagnostic et tout ce oui
c'est assez clair qu'elle que j'en ai un
qui me solaire je pense pour pour en
tant qu'artiste c'est utile parce que
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'idées le think
outside the box est très lent mais aussi
l'hyper focus quand j'ai une idée faut
que je la fasse que je la fasse tout de
suite faut que je l'amène à terme puis
sinon je m'étonne c'est fait pour ça que
je produis vite comme ça mais oui j'en
ai un pied la spontanéité
aussi faut qu'à soi le
puis je pense que ça m'aide aussi à
vulgariser en fait c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'a aidé
à toujours garder en tête comment garder
l'attention de quelqu'un qui en a pas
beaucoup c'est sa mère de savoir comment
un enfant fonctionne en termes de
concentration et comment vous choisissez
vos sujets parce que ça va vous l'avez
dit de sujets très sérieux comme les
réfugiés un très beau livre vous
expliquez aux enfants la guerre
d'enfants les conséquences de la guerre
à les moustiques
ou champignons les patates à vélo les
patates à vélo cox avoue vient comment
il ya une progression je pense dans ma
façon de travailler le mot premier liste
une surprise puisque le catalogue des
gaspilleurs qs austère un travail de de
pratiquer d'exercices de style en
illustration ce que je commence à faire
de l'illustration
j'aime les petites îles donc je me suis
donné des faux client puis j'ai inventé
des publicités des concepts
publicitaires a réalisé en illustration
fait que j'ai inventé toujours de
niaiseries pour me faire du voile en
même temps pour être capable de
pratiquer et puis quand j'ai fini ça je
me suis dit est peut-être temps que les
enfants aiment rester puis après l'avoir
fait je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait un potentiel
d'éducation sur la surconsommation on
nous propose pas mal d'affaires dont on
n'a pas besoin dans la société ça gaze
pays ça nous fait ça ne fait pas notre
argent puis tout ce qui sépare bon pour
la planète puis
les profs ont commencé à l'utiliser pour
parler de ça aussi et puis moi j'ai aimé
tout parce que c'est un message qui vit
qui nous tient à coeur dans
l'environnement aussi la surconsommation
tout seul puis après ça je me suis rendu
compte que je pouvais très bien combiner
les deux le faire des trucs absurde
juste pour le fun mais il ya tout un
message après je me souviens apprécié
beaucoup ma tribune je me souviens
apprécié le fait que j'avais une façon
parle aux enfants puissent passer des
messages qui fonctionnait que les
enfants écoutent et que les profs
apprécié que les parents appréciaient je
me suis mis à le faire de façon plus
consciente j'ai choisi des sujets
stéréotypes sexuels mais ça c'est le
premier à faire c'est le premier budget
les les garçons peuvent être sensibles
ils peuvent péter il était oui des
images là justement qui vont qui vont
frapper c'est à développer là dessus où
elle sent que ça soit trop lourd
vous dites oui j'ai emmené sage a passé
mais faut que ce soit ludique encore il
faut - refn péter puer est en colère et
tout ce que j'avais fait ça en entendant
une entrevue à radio canada je ne suis
plus avec qui qui disait que les filles
avaient encore les filles et les femmes
avaient encore il y avait encore
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
exprimer beaucoup et pas très bien
toléré les femmes qui explique la grille
et qui exprime la colère moi je suis une
maman de deux filles et moi aussi j'ai
l'impression de ne pas l'exprimer
souvent c'est que ça soit pas bien
accueilli avec une fausse fasse quelque
chose pour les filles pour leur dit le
droit
c'est comme ça qu'est née sa première
affiche un message destiné à ses deux
filles qu'elle pouvait être ce qu'elle
voulait les affiches sont ensuite
enchaînés comme un exutoire pour son
côté engagé le respect la différence les
changements climatiques
l'autisme l'intimidation
l'amitié et les erreurs et les affiches
des listes gravel voyage maintenant
partout dans le monde
les affiches qui aura tout ce que je
fais c'est une énorme partie de ma
carrière en ce moment ça ça me fait
rentrer dans les écoles dans les
bibliothèques dans les ruelles j'ai vu
mes affiches imprimées dans des ruelles
plastifié sur des poteaux je ne sais si
on may cry 2 partout dans le monde on
les traduit on me dit gt affiche en
catalan 60 voyages partout puis offrir
des ressources aux écoles aux profs puis
aux parents qui n'ont pas nécessairement
qu'ils ont pas les moyens de se trouver
ce hold on me le demande ça me fait
plaisir de le faire puis envie de faire
plus de sous c'est mon engagement
politique personnelle et sans lendemain
et comment vous tracer la ligne entre
cet engagement lors que vous avez pu
vous avez envie de partager des valeurs
puis combattre en fait certaines choses
les inégalités le sexisme et sait
comment fut tracée l'alliance sopi l'art
parce que souvent vous aide il ya des
émissions pour enfants pendant une
période ça a été trop un message pour
vous la rentrée le message éducatif
oui et on perdait la fantaisie on
perdait le côté fanfreluches d'être trop
jeune mais qui racontent des histoires
pour des histoires puis oui moral mais
sont loin derrière comment vous
réconcilier le côté auteur je raconte
des histoires que les enfants envie de
lire quand même temps je veux passer des
médecins elle sur cette scène c'est
quelque chose qui ne travaille pas tout
le temps puis-je alterne souvent jeu
mais j'ai un sujet qui veut moi même
j'ai beaucoup de sujets qui me touchent
le ca me fasse ce que j'entends ça c'est
ce qui se passe dans le monde mais
ferait il ya à côté de moi qui veut
partager ce message là j'en ai besoin
pour me faire du bien à moi c'est du
bénévolat c'est de l'action l'action
sociale d'engagement et j'ai besoin de
faire ça des fois je sais ça pendant un
petit bout de temps je fais quelques
livres sur des thèmes vraiment précis
puis après je trouve selon moi même je
tombe à l'eau moi j'ai besoin d'eux mais
aussi puis
moi je lis pas pour m'informer seulement
gilles pour m'informer celui du
documentaire mais je lis aussi des
romans policiers juste pour décrocher
les enfants ont besoin de ça aussi c'est
que j'alterne entre les deux mais des
fois dans le même livre via moyens
d'alterner aussi de faire quelque chose
qui est éducatif sans que les enfants
s'en rendre compte faisons de parenthèse
sur les réfugiés c'est en ce moment avec
la guerre en ukraine ainsi fuji c'est
une personne comme toi et moi la fuji
ont dû quitter leur pays parce qu'il s'y
était en danger certains sont partis
pour échapper à la guerre
d'autres se sont en fait parce que le
gouvernement au pouvoir ne naît pas leur
opinion il en voulait du mal si on a
besoin d'un instrument pour expliquer
aux enfants pourquoi quand il ya des
guerres des famines ou des crises
économiques qui vous des gens qui
cherchent un monde meilleur c'est ça
votre moteur où vous vouliez expliquer
quelque chose qui peut paraître complexe
a détruit ses caisses c'est quelque
chose qui est important pour moi c'est
d'aider les enfants à connecter avec ce
qui attend les sujets dont ils entendent
aller entendre la gagnante en est
réfugié aucun pouvoir les enfants
là-dessus savent pas de quoi on parle
mais savent que ça a l'air vraiment
inquiétant et je trouvais que
ce livre a été écrit avant la garante du
crime évidemment je trouvais que les
enfants entendu ce mot là tout le temps
mais dans les médias c'est est mentionné
comme un problème de crise des réfugiés
le problème des réfugiés qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les réfugiés comme c'était un
problème et c'est des êtres humains puis
je me disais je veux pas que les enfants
apprennent qu'un réfugié c'est un
problème une crise je qui apprennent que
c'est un être humain il ya un nom dans
leur école il ya des classes d'accueil
ici au québec je voulais que les enfants
apprennent merci une personne comme toi
tu as juste vécu des choses difficiles
peu différente et puis comme si tout
était pour qu'ils puissent se connecter
avec avec les réfugiés fax et c'est
quelque chose que je veux
je veux communiquer avec les enfants
je faire un pont en ce que les adultes
puisque les enfants peuvent comprendre
pour générer l'empathie c'est des petits
clis le 4 ans des fois c'est un sujet
l'eau qui fait de la peine
c'est difficile ses parents ça peut
c'est quelque chose qui peut qui peut
être lourd à apprendre pour un enfant je
peux pas mettre des blagues dans le
livre sur les réfugiés c'est impossible
je peux pas faire passer ça de façon
ludique donc ça va tout pensé par
l'empathie l'empathie les enfants non ça
ne revienne à tourelle l'empathie pour
les réfugiés mais l'empathie pour le
lecteur aussi l'enfant a besoin qu'on
lui amène soit avec douceur pour qu' il
puisse un type comme envers ce absorber
cette france-là des autres sans prendre
sur ses épaules aussi parce que ça ça
peut être qu'ils sont se sentir coupable
c'est ça des ports responsable n'était
responsable d'essayer de comprendre ce
qu'ils vivent puis 2 2 d'essayer de te
mettre dans leurs souliers un peu au
moins pour pas voir l'autre comme danger
comme une menace ou s'éteint c'est un
ami potentiel donc vous allez alterné
comme centre des affaires farfelues oui
et les jo c'est plus sérieux n'est
avec une transposition
sentir voulez vous que je vous parle de
mon prochain projet sérieux alors
prochain sujet sérieux qui s'en vient
que ça avait un livre pour pluvieux sur
la désinformation l'effet que news sur
wii et ben je l'aimais d'amélie déguisé
je sais même pas si les enfants vont
savoir ces équipements sûrement qu'ils
ont encore savoir c'est qui mais c'est
pour les mettons 5e 6e année ça c'est un
sujet qui me ce qui me faisait vraiment
c'est ça me tient vraiment à coeur le
fait là la peur de la science de la part
des médias j'ai offert deux toute cette
méfiance que là c'était super important
pour moi que les enfants apprennent tout
de suite à déterminer où se trouvaient
des outils en fait pour déterminer c'est
quoi une nouvelle information
scientifique comment on fait en fait
pour démêler tous il va sortir chez
chronicle books aux états unis zoo qui
voulaient sortir avant les beatles et il
trouve ça important à ce point là de
parler aux enfants donc ça en septembre
aux états unis il va sortir jusqu'à la
ch'ti qui si on essaie de le sortir plus
ou moins en même temps mais ça c'est un
livre dont je suis vraiment très fier je
l'ait rendue très drôle ça va être super
drôle j'invente des théories de
conspiration hilarante
défèque news qui ressemblent chez sas et
à ce que les enfants vont pouvoir voir
dans la réalité pour que je fasse un
lien sans qui semble que garde source
d'une fausse nouvelle société ils vont
pouvoir eux mêmes voir ce qu'on essaie
de la revendre en termes de médias
en 2021 sainte livre d'eli ce grave elle
se retrouve dans la liste des 50 titres
les plus vendus au québec une patate à
vélo par exemple publié en 2016 a
largement dépassé la barre des 100000
exemplaires vendus un exploit dans le
monde de l'édition tous genres confondus
le livre est traduit dans une vingtaine
de langues
élise gravel est une rock star de
l'édition pour enfants ici au québec
évidemment mais aussi de plus en plus
aux etats unis
son livre à paraître sur les fausses
nouvelles les fake news pour paraphraser
s'annonce comme un grand succès à
l'automne et publié en anglais lui
permet d'avoir le luxe de ralentir
anglais français ça c'est intéressant
parce que là vous êtes rendus à niveau
ou publié en anglais d'abord d'abord en
français ensuite pourquoi parce que je
t'aime beaucoup plus d'argent
si je fais aux états unis d'abord les
avances sont
vraiment beaucoup plus grosse donc je
peux me permettre de vivre de faire un
livre pis dans vivent ici au québec
c'est beaucoup plus difficile d'en vivre
papa pour moi maintenant je pourrais lui
mais c'est rare dans l'illustration puis
dans le livre jeunesse mais il y en a
que je fais seulement au québec et des
livres qui sont que je fais parce que
pour moi sociaux livres québécois c'est
aux livres canadiens
puis je fais ici à 20 donc ça dépanne
mais c'est une question évidemment de
whist une question de gros sous parce
que si vous n'aviez que les revenus pour
pour des livres que vous avez vendu au
canada au québec de vous vous verriez
pas de sots vraiment à oui moi
maintenant maintenant oui mais
assurément je veux dire c'est le livre
d'enfant vous permettrait la de vie bien
moi je pourrais vise bien ici avec
seulement le québec maintenant mais sait
jamais
j'ai depuis peu depuis wayne depuis peu
j'aurais ça fait presque presque 20 ans
que je fais des lits je réponds c'est la
plus grosse partie de saut
je devais prendre d'autres contrôles des
contrats publicitaires des trucs comme
ça c'est impossible d'arrêter impossible
quand je commençais l'on avait 2000
dollars d'avancé pour faire un livre ça
s'apprend 6 mo farah lit
non tu peux pas vivre de sousse était
absolument impossible fallait absolument
faire des trucs alimentent par exemple
patate à vélo vous en avez vendu combien
puis combien sa mesure pas si je peux
vous demander ça mais ça rapporte condé
il ya beaucoup de travail là dedans
c'est un gros gros gros succès les gens
ont l'impression de s'être fait une
fortune je ne sais pas je ne sais pas d
en espaçant clive donc j'ai pas capable
de tenir le compte de chacune de mes
publications puisque ça rapporte ou pas
je ne sais pas pour la patate à vélo
c'est
j'aime pas vraiment soir garde des
sceaux non plus au bar détaille de
livres parce que sinon ça va j'ai peur
que ça met dans un
mode d'esprit de je veux faire un livre
qui valent au sens je sais ce qu'ils
sortent un peu de fard soit pour ça je
veux faire des livres parce que le sujet
me ton pied que je sais pas parler mais
je sais que dans moi j'ai pas de
j'ai pas du tout de problème
d'argent puis au québec depuis quelques
années je pourrais vivre de ce que je
fais au québec 16 mai publiés aux états
unis comme ce sera le cas pour le sujet
sur l'effet que news ça vous amène
ailleurs quand même oui ça me donne un
énorme visibilité aux 6 et c'est super
c'est intéressant parce que c'est un
marché absolument différent les éditeurs
fonctionnent pas de la même façon le
marché est vraiment différent c'est
beaucoup plus le fan de faire des livres
au québec on a beaucoup plus de liberté
on a marché absolument fantastique mais
où ça une culture du livre pour enfants
qui est qui et spectaculaire je fais des
livres partout dans le monde il n'y a
rien comme le québec pour
la liberté d'être déjanté des captures
d'être irrévérencieux
vous voyez continuer à faire ça
plusieurs années sous cette forme là est
ce que vous pensez des produits dérivés
la télévision des tranquilles non mais
je veux plus g
j'ai essayé un peu dans produits dérivés
mais j'ai des agents qui mangeait une
agente aux états unis qui me pousse tout
le temps pour la télé pour les produits
dérivés mais
j'en ai fait quelques uns c'est pas
quelque chose j'aime pas ça j'ai
l'impression moi je veux faire des
bisous c'est ce que j'aime faire j'aime
faire des dessins j'aime inventer des
histoires le format le format livre me
plaît beaucoup mais oui je vais
continuer c'est certain mais je garde
encore mon objectif de ralentir jeu
souhaitez moi bonne chance je sais pas
si je vais réussir je vais me promener
mon chien je veux qu'à lire des
champignons peut-être faire juste comme
cinq livres par année ça sera suffisant
[Rires]
en cette ère de rectitude la pensée du
langage et du choix des mots certains
éditeurs commencent à engager des
réviseurs même pour les livres qui
s'adresse aux enfants
si certains y voient avec raison une
pente dangereuse
élise gravel assume son côté web pour
reprendre le mot à la mode elle n'a
aucun problème avec les remises en
question les doutes au contraire on peut
plus rien dire ça ne dérange pas moi
qu'on puisse plus rien dire je veux dire
on peut dire plein d'affaires jusqu'au
bout est ce qu'on peut réfléchir
ensemble à comment on dit ça ça me fait
plaisir de réfléchir à comment j'ai quel
mot j'utilise je n'ai pas de problème
avec ça
et évidemment moi aussi il faut que je
fasse évoluer mon langage puymoyen des
blagues que j'ai fait dans certains
livres que que je voudrais pas que je
comprends pas pourquoi j'ai fait cette
blague lui le monde évolue puis moi
aussi je prête à évoluer mais
franchement je pourrais pas dire que
j'ai une créativité bris mais là je suis
absolument libre j'ai du fun je me
je veux être quelqu'un de plus sensible
je veux plus d'empathie moi aussi je
veux comprendre mieux le monty manteau
puis je veux les enfants la prochaine
génération il va avoir des sensibilités
qui voit une différente de la mienne je
veux suivre le sol moi c'est correct
pour moi de suivre ce qui sans vie puis
ce qui est pas parce que moi j'ai appris
je crois qu'avec ça
clé de son titre à une rave il demande
la nourriture demande est la plus noire
[Musique]
est ce que pour mesurer à quel point
vous êtes dans les fans et dans beaucoup
de familles du québec une vedette comme
vous êtes les gens lisent vos livres les
mamans les papas les enfants vous êtes
quelqu'un qui est entré dans les
familles oui oui je sais puis c'est je
le vois de plus en plus je reçois je
reçois beaucoup d'amour je reçois au
salon du livre à un jeu de salon du
livre je me sens comme une commune
rockster j'ai des longues files
d'attentes déjà qu'ils montrent qu'ils
vont s'évanouir devant moi mais je
reçois des gersois mais j'ai des animaux
des toutous de mme émond ce que les gens
m'envoient j'ai reçu hier matin une
photo d'un gâteau que quelqu'un à fiat
sim c'est une pile de mes livres met en
garde il ya des enfants qui sont qui
sont fans au point de demander des fêtes
d'anniversaire sur le thème élise gravel
s'est fixé je me sens moi que je le sais
que je rentre dans les familles
ça me fait extrêmement chaud au coeur
j'ai envie de continuer pour ça en fait
je pense qu'elles les commentaires qui
me touche le plus c'est très sauvage
heures je reçois souvent le commentaire
de mon enfant voulait voler mon enfant
ne sait rien puis depuis qu'ils ont
trouvé vos livres maintenant ils lisent
ça c'est le plus beau commentaire j'ai
réussi à toucher un enfant qui aimait
pas la lecture pic s'est mis à lire puis
des fois ça au départ soit c'est un
commentaire que j'ai eus qui je me tente
pas l'envoyer - les 10 commentaires
elle existe ça me fait très plaisir j'en
eus des superbes aussi s'aider des
parents immigrants qui parlait pas
français qui m'ont écrit pour me dire
mon enfant à l'école moi c'est difficile
d'apprendre le français mais mon enfant
ramène vos livres à la maison puis on
aime les lisons les lie ensemble on rit
en français ensemble puis
j'ai des témoignages comme seul qui sait
c'est impossible que j'arrête de faire
ce travail là c'est je me sens utile
dans les familles les lys grèce était un
plaisir de vous rencontrer vraiment
continuer c'est très inspirant ce que
vous faites entre copines c'était
lassant de voir quelque chose qui
fonctionne
merci beaucoup d'amour versions d'entrée
dans ma prochaine
[Musique]